قالوا ان ابنك مستشهد بغزه وهو واصحابه طب
ما في لا نت ولا تواصل ولا جوال قعدنا
نعيط اربعه ايام معاناه يعني ما انام مش
طول الليل ولا اعرف
اقعد انا اسمي مطه بكر والله معانه له انا
بدي اطلع من المشوار لهان واحمل كمان
الغسيل وارجع فيه تعب علي وما فيش ميه
نهائي ومابقا زي غسيل انه كله بصير على
بياض في على الحبال بضبط معنا بس ماشي
بحال انا من مخيم الشاطئ من غزه احنا اول
حاجه طلعنا من دارنا قصفوا مربع حوالينا
واستشهدوا ناس يعني بجي يمكن 150 شهيد
طلعنا على خانيونس
برضه قصفنا بخانيونس
ولا اخذنا فراش ولا اواعي حتى بلطيه ما
قدرت اخذه لانه الدبابات كان ورا المدرسه
واولادي
شرت انا واولادي اجينا هنا قالوا ان ابنك
مستشهد بغزه وهو واصحابه طب ما فيش لا نت
ولا تواصل ولا جوال قعدنا نعيط اربعه ايام
معانه يعني ما انا مش طول الليل ولا اعرف
اقعد لما اجوا قالوا لا مش هو وحتى الان
نفسي بس اسمع صوته نفسي اسمع صوته يطمني
اذا هو بيحضر هذا
الفيديو بده يسمع منك كلمه ايش بتحكي
بقوله دير بالك على حالك
اخواتك وبلك يعني شاف اي جوال طمني بس
اتصل
علي وبتمنى انه يفتحه يجي ابني اشوفه
يجيني ه يقعد
عندي احنا هون ساكنين لا تابعين ل مدرسه
ولا وكاله ولا حكومه ولا حد بدعمنا ولا حد
بجيبنا حاجه والله بحب اوجه رسالتي انه
ربنا ينصرنا احسن من كل شيء لربنا هو احسن
شيء بس نن والله احسن من غيرنا اقول لك
ليش في ناس قاعدين على ال على الرمل وعلى
الارض والشوارع ننا لسه اننا اوضه تسكر
علينا يعني الحمد لله لا ببحر جوره وبدفن
حالي ولا بطلع من غزه انا اصلا اكبر غلطه
انا طلعت من غزه لو متنا في غزه لسه احسن
اقل ما فيها بتموتي في دارك اي عندك كل
شيء ه نحن ولا شيء ننا قاعدين هون مش زي
ما انت شايفه
فيش بعد بلده الواحد يموت الجوع في بلده
ولا يطلع عند اي بني
ادم ان شاء الله يا رب نتحرر وننتصر ونرجع
على غزه وانا متامله اكثر منفك قدامي ان
ان شاء الله غير ارجع على غزه حتى لو عن
طريق البحر رجعها
[موسيقى]
ماشي
ه